[Musique]
dans ce nouveau numéro 2 par soixante
dix huit retours sur la 17e édition des
balles blanches qui a eu lieu le 5 juin
dernier au golf du prieuré
on en parle avec son fondateur eric
duquesne et avec le gardien de but que
tout le monde adore jérôme alonzo un
golf à six minutes de la défense et oui
ça existe c'est le golf de l'ue fleury
on en parle avec sa directrice est
propriétaire valérie car le baril bhl si
vous ne savez pas encore ce qu'est un
fitting on va vous le faire découvrir
avec le pot julien guillerme et ses
clubs à peu particulier ils ont tous la
même taille
[Musique]
alors suis avec eux eric duquenne qui le
fondateur et organisateur des balles
blanches c'était le seizième édition
avec un tort eric je pense que vous avez
eu la trouille aujourd'hui oui c'est
vrai
ce matin sa tombe est sévère et en fait
au coup de canon la pluie s'est arrêtée
donc on a quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de chance et la fête continue ce soir
les enfants sont sont venus à une
trentaine on a réussi à les sortir de
l'hôpital au moins une journée dans
l'année donc on va dire contrat rempli
sont repartis avec la banane et c'est ce
qui compte c'est ce qui compte il faut
dire que c'est ça l'essentiel des balles
blanches alors c'est une compétition de
golf
il y en a plusieurs d'ailleurs dans
l'année il ya une grande qui est au
prieuré chaque année au mois de juin
mais le bénéfice de tout ça ce sont des
enfants hospitalisés
tout à fait ces rassemblements c'est
pour financer des projets pour améliorer
le quotidien des enfants hospitalisés ou
de famille
on étudie chaque cas et c'est vraiment
pour leur donner un petit peu plus de
sourires et qu'ils puissent en profiter
un peu plus le un enfant ça ne mérite
qu'une chose c'est profiter de la vie à
pleines dents absolument et c'est ça qui
fait du bien et qui fait le le sourire
des enfants c'est aussi le sourire de
leurs parents aussi qui sont là et de
tous les gens qui viennent ici et je
sais pas s'il ya quelqu'un qui aime
quelqu'un qui écoute et qui fait en
sorte que vint le jour de la compétition
des balles blanches y est voilà de la
météo s'arrête il ya pendant quelque
temps pour que pour que les gens
refusent d'y jouer et pour que les
enfants puissent avoir le sourire c'est
un peu ça
tout à fait en plus de ça bon il ya
quelques malheureusement quelques
personnes qui nous ont quittés les
l'année dernière et donc voilà entre
autres certains enfants de sion que
cette journée leur est dédié et pour moi
ils sont avec nous aujourd'hui donc
voilà pourquoi tout le monde se mobilise
il pleuvait énormément ce matin les gens
sont venus quand même ils ont dévalisé
prochain pour acheter mais au moins ils
étaient là ils savaient pourquoi il
était là et c'est ça qui est si ce qui
est bien et il faut rendre hommage aussi
alors c'est vous qui quittait la tête
tout ça mais de tous les bénévoles qui
sont autour de vous et qui font un
travail absolument exceptionnel pendant
toute l'année mais tout à fait déjà il
ya il y a nathalie innocenti qui est mon
bon droit et en fait me fait un travail
extraordinaire surtout que je suis très
pris professionnellement parlant et met
à me faire un travail et de lenteurs
restaurant dans le xvème six appels aux
trois présidents suite à mon parcours et
vous étiez à l'elysée et qui t'as fait
ça soit parce qu'il est toujours les
cuisines de l'elysée qui sont là tout à
fait les cuisiniers de l'elysée qui
viennent bénévolement ils ont préparé
ils ont travaillé tout le week end m'ont
préparé 1200 repas pour cette journée
nous avons une soixantaine de bénévoles
qui pose des jours pour venir
mais c'est tout ça c'est tout ça une
anglicisation et sans eux mêmes et sans
eux on ne peut pas organiser une journée
tels que la journée des balles blanches
au golf du prieur blanche et puis c'est
derrière tout ça le sourire pendant au
moins quelques heures des des enfants et
ça c'est cci rien de plus beau il n'y a
rien de plus beau surtout quand vous
avez un enfant qui vous dit en partant
j'ai oublié l'hôpital donc tout ça ça me
ça m'émeut
voilà bravo eric et puis alors il y aura
une 17e saison il y aura une 17e saison
et en plus de ça toujours fidèle au
poste patrice carmouze qui répond
automatiquement présent et je tenais
mois que j'y vois là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai toujours au prieuré vos
balles blanches avec jérôme alonzo
bonjourbonjour pas alors guardian
mythique ni saint-etienne nantes paris
saint germain
ça c'est l'oubli marseille tout on n'est
pas obligé de prouver
marseille aussi
marseille aussi vous êtes quelques uns à
avoir fait marseille et l'om et le psg
on est quelques-uns c'est un honneur une
fierté et en même temps de lougres
s'inquiéter mais un des leurs avant tout
et la carrière de football
aujourd'hui viennent une autre carrière
qui est celle de consultant sur france
télévisions pour exactement et l équipe
possible et à la chaîne l'équipe depuis
depuis très peu de temps devait
rejoindre ce groupe magnifique mené par
estelle denis
oui mais voilà l'équipe austère équipe
des stades absolument pour toute la
coupe du monde et a priori pour toute la
saison 2018 2019 voilà donc cumul des
fonctions
c'est bien c'est bien sûr yves un
événement comme ça comme la coupe du
monde
le double vous avez été enfin que vous
êtes toujours dans la tête qu'on vient
sur comment il vit ça comme un gamin en
fait avec des yeux d'enfant parce que
j'avais eu la chance de la jouer
et donc je n'ai pas de frustration du
deal justement j'ai j'ouvre un gros
paquet cadeau à chaque fois c'est ça la
coupe du monde si on ne sait pas ce
qu'on va trouver dans ces attaques et
surprise il va y avoir des super bas je
peux voir des matchs pourris et veut
regarder appelé les gardiens évidemment
beaucoup 1,5 l'an sachant j'ai pas à
part votre moi quand je pousse au pied
on est plus c'est ça qui a changé huawei
a pris sont un petit peu plus physique
il ya moins de petits gardiens mais bien
sûr les entraîneurs leur demande leur
demande de jouer au pied de relancer
comme comme les libéraux à l'époque
numéro les lycéens que aller-retour aux
lancers longs sur un grand devant et ben
non relances courtes ou toucher les
joueurs rapides au milieu dont voici
qu'à changer coup là bon pour moi parce
que moi les pieds les poings c'était bon
ouais les points des papiers la france à
votre avis un peu petite chance et
conseille des outsiders raisonnable on
va dire mais voilà je pense à une
carreau deux miss est raisonnable de
dépenser alors un mot sur le golf qui
est devenu aussi notre deuxième pression
s'était longtemps
ça fait un moment toujours beaucoup joué
très bien c'est vrai je joue comme
beaucoup derrière de deux sportifs ont
beaucoup de footballeurs des exactement
il ya tout un clan de football groupe
madar et notamment ceux qui se moquaient
de nous il ya 20 ans qui nous attendent
et d'abandon dugarry par exemple les
tops qui qui se moquaient nous ya dix
ans et qui est complètement mordu
aujourd'hui négociant à la boghossian
qui en a qui nous emmène tous évidemment
les niveaux de proxim ans et puis voilà
tout un groupe
il se disait c'est un sport de vieux les
vieux on sort mieux quand on a le droit
et c'est n'importe quoi le le golf parce
qu'elle même des joueurs mais qui sont
maintenant sur le sur les terrains qui
jouent vraiment passé un nouveau
challenge mais c'est à dire que moi j'ai
toujours goal compétition chaque
compétiteur avec jour mon lockhart au
golf j'ai besoin de gagner ces bons
d'essence c'est comme ça que je vis et
je trouvais ce challenge là maintenant
dans le golfe oui je pourrais c'est
beaucoup
en train d'ailleurs beaucoup déjà groupe
copains dans le sud royal bouge à call
flop québec est bon golf d'adoption où
on se tire la bourre et ce qui me plaît
au-delà du la beauté des sites c'est la
compétition et est de toujours tenir un
mois je suis comme ça jusqu'à ma mort
parce que ba vi essayer de gagner et je
peux pas supporter de dire on joue pour
participer c'est bien participer à part
aujourd'hui c'est un cas à part les
balles blanches pour les enfants la
maison n'ont pas là mais apparaît ça à
part une fois on joue pour gagner
non c'est pas la peine justement à
mougins vous faites une correction pour
les palplanches balle blanche
vous avez été le parrain de cette
manifestation fait pendant des années
est ce que c'est important pour
quelqu'un comme ça qu'il ya des voix qui
est un sportif qui inquiète toutes les
rives et d'invoquer ses muscles pour lui
de donner quelque chose justement à ses
enfants
c'est un devoir à l'hôpital et sa devoir
c'est pas une envie c'est pas besoin
c'est un devoir
on doit le faire on doit se bouger les
fesses j'ai la chance d'avoir une bonne
image dans le milieu du sport en général
ce qui fait que j'ai tous les copains
qui viennent qui veut suivre cette
aventure un peu folle
je suis quasiment seul organisé ça a les
clés du royal golf et on reçoit 150
personnes sur un petit site et c'est du
boulot mais
je prends pas ça comme c'est pas une
gloriole personnelle c'est ça de voir
qu'on a
j'ai aidé et vicat nathalie pendant des
années mais en venant ici
maintenant je prends le flambeau je les
aide un peu en organisant cette belle
compet à mougins et vous êtes fidèle à
ce rendez vous du prix exact en quoi que
ça de voir ces des enfants parfois en
fabriquant des vents difficulté les
parents on parle des enfants mais les
parents souffrent semestre oui c'est
très délicat alors sourire s'amuser un
peu avec le haut alors ces deux jours
par an mais c'est déjà énorme
c'est tout bon c'est toujours par an si
tout le monde faisait jour par enfant
sortir alors on va vous voir donc cet
été pour le pour la coupe du monde cet
été je vais en juillet mais qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous comment vous
envisagez vous de votre site de votre de
votre carrière seulement moi toujours le
consultant le consultant c'est pour ça
que c'est bien ça me plaît bien c'est du
boulot travailler il faut pas cher et ça
me plaît j'ai pas fait le tour de ses 45
ans je me suis fixé jusqu'à 50 ans pour
faire ça et puis à 50 ans
bien évidemment merci beaucoup de la
ryder cup bat les couilles où je vais
dormir devant un battant et je ne vais
pas parce que c'est compliqué ce
compliqué et qui ont dû être arrêtés
[Musique]
dans ce numéro 2 par soixante dix huit
je voudrais vous présenter un parcours
qui se situe à 6 minutes de la défausse
à dix minutes de la porte maillot dans
les yvelines
c'est le parcours de lille fleuri sur
l'île des impressionnistes à côté de
château
on en parle avec sa directrice est
propriétaire valérie car le baril
[Musique]
oh
je suis en compagnie de valérie car le
baril qui est la directrice est la
propriétaire du golf de l'île fleury on
dit souvent gold de chatou mais elle
tarde à tort parce que ces carrières sur
seine et on aperçoit d'ailleurs derrière
nous le village à flanc de coteau de
carrières sur seine qui est juste
magnifique
mais on accède par le point de chatou et
par la commune de château c'est
complètement sur une île on est bordée
par la scène de chaque côté alors on est
aussi dans ce qu'on appelle ville des
impressionnistes un humour noir
tous les grands peuples qui sont venus
dans ce lieu oui c'était pas le golf ou
encore est effectivement donc vous
accédez on est proche de la maison
fournaise nous avons besoin au lieu
impressionnistes et et ici on ont été
peints de fameux tableau d'ailleurs
c'est vrai que les points de vue sont
toujours aussi magnifique parce que ça
très très peu bougé carrière n'a pas
changée parce qu'ils y parle alors de
l'autre côté c'est un peu différent
parce que voilà si on se retourne on
peut voir la défense en étant ici à peu
près à ce trou on va dire entre le green
du 8 et celui du 2 mai on a d'un côté de
village de carrière et de l'autre la
défense voilà il faut dire qu'on aime ou
pas cette nuit six minutes de la défense
à peu près ici voilà exactement à six
minutes de la défense dix minutes de là
dès la porte maillot donc donc tout fait
tout près de paris et donc c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un golf urbain or
il n'a pas du tout la parole flou c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire parce que
c'est vrai que c'était le premier golf
urbain de l'île de france
et pourtant quand vous arrivez sur l'île
alors c'est vrai qu'il est on arrive
très vite au point de château et vous
roulez sur 1 km et vous arrivez vraiment
dans une oasis et là on est en pleine
campagne au bout du monde
on est en pleine campagne là c'est un
golf qui a été construit dans les années
90 un tout petit peu avant 89 je crois
que vous avez pris en charge cinq ans
plus tard à peu près exactement donc je
gère et je suis propriétaire de ce golf
depuis 1994
donc voilà te dire l'heureuse pour prier
parce que c'est
c'est un lieu exceptionnel comme cela et
j'ai apprécié chaque jour
voilà donc c'est un esprit tout à fait
familial aussi ce qui peut paraître
parfois un peu antinomique en se disant
golf urbain on imagine quelque chose
d'un personnel c'est pas du tout le cas
donc on a voilà moi ça fait 25 ans que
je suis là et une équipe de qui est là
aussi puis depuis très longtemps donc
très humain un endroit où les gens
aiment bien se retrouver mais il ya en
effet un club assez un restaurant quant
au titre carrefour urbain c'est parce
que voilà c'était un neuf trous
on peut le faire encore combien de temps
à peu près on peut le jouer en une heure
et demie une réduit voilà donc
aujourd'hui c'est extraordinaire parce
que ça permet à tout à chacun c'est vrai
que prendre une demi journée pour aller
faire un parcours de golf lui c'est bon
c'est long c'est un lien à la famille
souvent il ya voilà il ya des clés de
travail
évidemment revenir entre midi et deux à
peu près on est ouvert toute l'année on
ferme tard et voilà on peut en une heure
et demie faire son parcours se classer
faire des compétitions sur 9 trous les
tests index donc c'est très accessible
et c'est un vrai don ne s'est pas du
tout que départ troyen par quatre ouais
mais un parcours qui a été dessiné par
au tri qui appartient au grand est
c'est un parcours qui est très technique
il ya des départs peut-être pour les
débutants parce qu'il a été conçu et à
la fois pour être un golf facilement
accessible puisque notre vocation
première était de former des nouveaux
golfeurs mais à la fois il avec des
départs ariary devient très technique
jouer à part trois maintenant le par
mais c'est pas évident il ya aussi alors
centre d'entraînement parce que je crois
que vous avez 150 postes de praticiens
ce gaz qui est énorme tout à fait 150
postes dont 110 postes couvert et puis
des postes éclairé donc oui donc toute
heure près parce que c'est ouvrir
jusqu'à quelle heure alors on est ouvert
le mercredi jusqu'à 23 heures
ah oui et puis le reste du temps suivant
la saison en trombe à 10h 19h et 20h30
oui donc donc loué la le mercredi on
peut venir le soir c'est vraiment le
goal qui est fait pour voilà les gens
qui sont urbains et qui peuvent aller
concert un peu de ton sens en prendre
cinq six heures comme on le fait que si
on veut faire un vrai parcours bah c'est
tout à fait ça vous pouvez arriver à
lille fleury et vous n'avez jamais joué
au golf et on va vous prendre en charge
donc ça c'est très important est de
garder cette ouverture ce côté club
accessible à tout le monde donc quelques
membres pour venir jouer ici neuf trous
ça secoue de combien un peu peur ça
varie en fonction des horaires puisque
s'ils achètent en ligne les tarifs
varient énormément en semaine entre 15
et 25 euros et le week end entre 20 et
35 euros
c'est tout à fait tout à fait accessible
et on peut aller sur le site internet
est comme ça il ya des horaires qui sont
plus ou moins cher que d'autres
exactement voilà et ont peu joué en fin
de journée n'acheter que quelques trous
voilà faire de 3,3 rentrant chez soi le
soir
alors on disait vous êtes à six minutes
de la défense la défense s'est beaucoup
d'entreprises il ya aussi des
entreprises dans les yvelines
il ya beaucoup aussi d'événementiel que
vous faites sur le golf de l'ifri c'est
une activité extrêmement importante du
site et nous avons de nombreuses salles
de séminaires en organise beaucoup
d'événements d'entreprises est également
familiaux et familiaux c'est ça alors on
peut réserver
il ya des deux salles ou lion rouge
prend exactement on peut réserver
organiser son mariage à une fête
d'anniversaire et le soir disposer du
club house comme d'une maison de
campagne puisque on organise un seul
événement le soir donc vous êtes chez
vous on vous laisse les clés on pourrait
de trouver un slogan c'est la campagne à
paris assis tout ça là bas alors venez
venez vite il fera d'abord et après se
distille yahia ya toute cette histoire
artistique et puis il ya ce dieu superbe
voilà où on peut venir soient joués soit
soit fêtée des événements voilà agréable
merci infiniment merci merci
si vous savez pas ce que c'est de
physique je vous expliquais s'asperge
wahre julien guillerme et vous allez
tout savoir alors je fais avec julien
guillerme bonjour vous êtes pro vous
êtes prof
oui c'est le golf et vous faites au golf
de luc ferry dans le désir line un
footing
alors qu'est ce que c'est d'abord of
heating un footing c'est tout bête c'est
c'est donc une séance où on va passer un
petit peu de temps avec une personne qui
cherche à voir du bon matériel et on va
l'adapter à sa taille à sa morphologie à
sion à sa vitesse de souligner on va
passer un petit peu de temps comme si
vous alliez par exemple chez un tailleur
et puis on va essayer sur mesure en
voilà c'est tout sur mesure alors c'est
sûr que la particularité du sur mesure
que je fais c'est que c'est un sur
mesure qui va bien qu'il a un petit peu
plus loin que ce qu'on peut retrouver
normalement c'est à dire que c'est moi
qui personnellement qui lui monte des
clubs dans mon atelier d'accor du fait
de les fabriquer je vais faire très
attention à bien harmonisé des clubs
entre l'idée c'est que la personne soit
bien avec tous ces clubs ne venez pas
qu'ils aient becker bien puis un autre
qui est un cas un petit peu moins bien
joué
alors il ya tout un matériel wyeth avec
vous il ya les ordinateurs pour prendre
la vitesse du swing la vitesse de la
balle et a fait tout à fait
il y avait une machine pour mettre les
des griffes oui alors ça c'est
intéressant c'est que
on peut par exemple avec moi faire un
footing et puis je vais faire essayer
des clubs à la personne avec vraiment le
bon grip qu'elle aime bien avec la bonne
taille
donc ça c'est que j'étais gerin
compressé personnalisés oui tout à fait
donc ça c'est assez c'est quand même
important et des têtes de club
évidemment absurde wet jusqu'au jusqu'au
fort et si j'ai un système qui est très
intéressant c'est que le donc j'ai
obligé d'installer ce
ce petit appareil dre ce petit système
pour pour accrocher le shaft mais il est
ultra léger il accra léger et j'enlève
donc pour vous donner des ifs et big g i
et j'enlève 8 g dans la tête à
l'intérieur pour pouvoir la série très
vite donc en fait il n'y a aucune
incidence de poids de poids souhaitent
souvent souvent les systèmes la croche
canton cross a fait un pas de plus en
fait voilà et c'est souvent à cause de
ce système les pièces qui pèse un peu
plus ce qui perturbe et qui fait que au
montage on pourra jamais avoir
exactement la même chose ce qu'il existe
toujours pas chez vous alors barbie les
les les clous présentait là il ya ce
cela qui sont assez incroyable parce que
ça va du sandwich je crois offert 5 du
lob wedge 71 et pour faire 4 et tous de
la même taille généralement un lounge
est comme ça et le fait qu'ils sont tous
et quel est l'intérêt alors de deux de
ses fers là c'est de prendre un club que
généralement tout le monde aime bien
qu'on n'est pas trop penché patron droit
devant la balle c'est le fer 8 de fer 8
ou faire moyens voilà pour tous les
golfeurs de nerfs de tout le monde aime
son nom mais voilà comment la jouer mais
tom wilson qui a fabriqué la série lui
il s'est dit comment je vais faire pour
pouvoir compenser parce que j'étais
quand même très impressionnant de deux
longueurs et un club un c'est très
simple même si les têtes ont le même
poids ouais ça c'est quand même là
j'irai le prédicat de base pour pouvoir
faire des clubs de la même taille et
bien toutes les têtes sont différentes
je m'explique quand vous prenez un club
ouvert de l'oft ya pas juger de la
boutique idée fait d'accord en fait si
vous voulez il ya une caractéristique
est très important dans un club de golf
c'est son effet rebond c'est à dire que
vous avez une face entre la grèce et ses
larges
alors qui est large mais qui est surtout
plus ou moins épaisses d'accord et plus
la face et fine plus les faits ce qu'on
appelle l'effet trampoline il sera
important
d'accord on appelle ça le coefficient de
restitution à 4 la vitesse de votre
swing et la vitesse de balle
quelle est la restitution d'accord donc
fait trampoline il ya un effet
trampoline et donc là on a une face
relativement épaisse
dans l'it besoin d'envoyer trop loin et
si on prend le faire 5 évidemment eu ces
bois voilà on a une phase donc beaucoup
plus fine vous plaît filles de ion qui
va avoir un coefficient de restitution
beaucoup plus important avec un fer 5
pour vous donner une idée ici on peut
augmenter quasiment de 50% la vitesse du
swing c'est à dire par exemple justesse
de sang ouais la balle peut partir à 150
avec ce qu'il va faire escale et essai
et c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
cette série à un succès aussi important
il faut faire la même longueur de club
et au fond par rapport à un fax cinq
normales on perd par deux distances
alors ça c'est une question qu'on peut
se poser mais je suscite la curiosité je
pensais que je dis aux gens venez il
faut garder l'essayer voilà et puis
peut-être que vous serez ravis d'avoir
un club plus court et qui vous donne une
assurance de distance que vous aviez
peut-être pas avec le faire 5 et dans
votre famille parce que c'est dur de le
contacter correctement et donc les
policiers
il faut essayer c'est vrai que c'est
séduisant et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me suis dit voilà il faut
vraiment que jax vraiment tous mes
efforts pour faire connaître cette série
parce que c'est une vraie bonne nouvelle
pour pour on va dire les joueurs qui
sont qui sont autour des entre 15 et 30
d'index comme d'accord donc ça peut être
très un mois qui sut projet avec jeu
très content très content d'avoir enfin
non au contraire de contraire comme ça
je trouve ça très très très agréable de
jouer avec
il ya même un fer 4 donc gimont faire
quatre dans le sac et je le sors
soulanges a déjà content donc le tout
c'est de cette veut dire essayer parce
que ça ne correspond ça dépend des ddd
du swing sa dépendent
elle des envies des besoins de chacun
jean yanne guillerme voilà ou alors j'ai
aussi un site internet pro golf maker
points comme et les gens donc peuvent
s'inscrire et réserver un meeting est
tout à fait qu'il t'arrive tout à
l'heure qui a essayé un les clubs de la
même longueur valider son accent d'avis
bonjour times
là bas vous avez de faire cinq que vous
avez essayé junien quel est votre
ressenti ça change énormément de dû
faire cinq que j'avais avant l'acquis
camp nou avec le physique quand j'ai
vérifié c'est plus sympa trois et demi
je n'ai jamais jamais plus je jouais
mais avec ce faire je m'en sors beaucoup
mieux ah bon donc avec celui-là vous
avec celui qui est plus court finalement
vous jouez faire 5 alors qu'avant vous
aviez un peu d'appréhension jouer je
joue plus je jamais moment faire 5 un
mois a donc c'est une bonne bonne bonne
expérience je vais me mettre rapidement
en faire des étudiants c'est bien merci
infiniment merci julien merci merci
patrice
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]